strange world no llegará a los cines de
francia la esperada película animada de
disney iba a llegar a las salas
cinematográficas francesas el 23 de
noviembre pero la compañía de
entretenimiento retiro el estreno por
una disputa con el gobierno acerca de su
ley de cronología de medios la normativa
determina el tiempo que debe transcurrir
antes de que una película estrenada en
cines puede estar disponible en
servicios de streaming
la nueva y engorrosa cronología de los
medios de comunicación es anti
consumidor e ignora cómo ha evolucionado
el comportamiento en los últimos años
seguiremos tomando decisiones película
por película y según las condiciones
únicas de cada mercado la decisión de
disney enfureció a la federación
nacional de cines de francia que la
calificó como una decisión que perjudica
a todos y que socavaría gravemente la
economía de los cines y del sector en su
conjunto
la disputa llega cuando las salas de
cine luchan por recuperar los niveles de
asistencia previos de la pandemia ahora
crece la preocupación de que otras
productoras sigan la medida de disney lo
que podría suponer una pérdida de
taquilla de 20 millones de entradas
anuales en francia
la norma de la industria de referente
las reglas de exhibiciones de 45 días
entre los estrenos en salas y la
transmisión en línea pero en francia esa
brecha es mucho más larga de 17 meses
aunque supone una mejora respecto a la
norma anterior de 36 meses
la medida busca proteger a la industria
cinematográfica francesa de las
superproducciones de hollywood que
abundan en streaming así como las
emisiones de televisión en abierto
también busca promover las entradas a
las salas de cine por ahora solo netflix
aceptó el acuerdo con los franceses
dejando en el aire el destino de otras
películas del estudio